dans ce camion les restes de 20 corps
non identifiés après plus de cinq mois
passés dans la morgue de boudhha il
charrie avec l'odeur de la mort
c'est le troisième enterrement de ce
type en moins d'une semaine dans le
cimetière de la ville
[Musique]
le père andry se tient seul parmi les
morts un dernier hommage sans aucune
famille pour pleurer ceux qui sont pour
le moment des anonymes
[Musique]
alors qu'ils sont inhumés ce prêtre
orthodoxe est là pour s'assurer qu'ils
ne seront pas oubliés
c'est très important pour nous de les
enterrer avec dignité de ne pas les
considérer comme de simples corps mais
comme des humains avec l'espoir de la
résurrection
identifier ces personnes est un défi sur
chaque cercueil un numéro qui relie
l'adn de la victime a une base de
données
cinquante corps doivent encore être
identifiées
ici à bout cha est partout en ukraine en
réalité nous n'étions pas préparés à
gérer un tel nombre de gens tués sur une
période aussi courte
près de six mois après le massacre de
boue de chasser dans des endroits comme
celui ci que le processus de guérison
peut commencer mais le deuil ne sera
jamais tout à fait complet tant qu'un
seul de ces corps n'aura pas de tombe à
son nom et une famille pour venir la
fleurir